well you know what Nancy we're gonna
find out tonight if bindi Irwin and
Derek Hough will rock the dancefloor and
Dancing with the Stars with some dirty
dancing you know they're practicing the
movie's most iconic move in a lake just
like Patrick Swayze and Jennifer Grey
did Jennifer even stopped by rehearsals
to give them a few tips also dropping by
bindis mother teri and younger brother
Robert they have been Bendis biggest
supporters and Cameron Mathison got to
see your amazing family bond firsthand
we are so close because we truly believe
that the meaning of life is
unconditional love and as a family we're
always there for each other
you're out there in the audience and
you're watching I mean that's your big
sister doing all that how'd you get like
you get butterflies to get nervous
whenever she walks out on stage there's
such an incredible presence and uh
currently taking your Lampe though Steve
Irwin is gone you get the sense that the
man who wants his family's hero husband
and father is what keeps them strong
they keep his legacy alive by being
respectful honest and fun
eleven-year-old Steve look-alike Robert
has definitely got that this one's my
garden it's a sprinkler ready yeah the
towel like this the young ladies out
there the young girls watching the show
they're like wow he's so cute well thank
you very much but I'm a lot more
interested in wildlife at the moment I
much rather go mom much rather go over
and hug a crocodile if you love
dinosaurs if you like photography he has
not Mountain by mountain biking yeah
yeah pepero Blio three we could do like
as for bindi while everybody has fallen
in love with her and Derek on dancing
and they're cheering for her
relationship with her 18 year old
boyfriend wakeboarder Chandler Powell do
you offer any parental advice on
relationships to your daughter
um I do I just remind them that I do
have a gun license so and we have access
to crocodiles as well Steven Terry
provided the perfect example of true
love for their kids it's the kind of
bond that can't be replaced
Terry told us she could never even
consider dating again I think I've had
my happily ever after and I still feel
immense love and loyalty to Steve and
I've got great kids I've got a very full
life and while I'm lonely for Steve I'm
not a lonely person so I'm doing okay
but I think if I hadn't met Steve I
probably wouldn't have
married that's kind of what how we go
through life is if we can talk about
what we've experienced and it can help
other people it's worth talking about so
it was like the biggies beautiful dance
with Derrick commemorating her dad I
think that was so special because she
was bringing everyone's grief journey
with with her on her journey and saying
you can lose someone and then find joy
again